[Music]
he's taking a crack
at something else besides crack
dulane university go worms has invited
hunter biden to be a guest speaker as
part of a 10-week course in the fall
the title of the course why cocaine is
awesome
[Laughter]
it's really called media polarization
and public policy impacts
and why meth is awesome the good news is
he will be spending 10 weeks in new
orleans
where there's never even the slightest
temptation to drink or do drugs
they were going to offer the class this
semester but they didn't want hunter on
the faculty during spring break
so many kids so many kids showed up to
register for this class
hunter said it was one of the longest
lines he's ever did i mean
[Applause]
the class is described as focusing on
the current state of the media landscape
in the united states and how media
polarization fake news and the economics
of the new business
impact public policy making in
washington d.c
so they're asking a hunter to speak
about fake news
but wasn't hunter's problem that the
news accurately describes his behavior
which lucky for him they don't do that
often remember this is the guy who
recently admitted he loved crack so much
he forgot often forgot to wear pants
sorry the only fake that bothers him is
when his lunch is cut with too much
baking soda
ryan i have no idea what that joke means
i mean like i
i don't have the interpretive arts yes
well what you need is you need a pan
uh it's it's complicated it's two betty
crocker
he is actually very good with a bunsen
burner he's probably should have done a
chemistry class
yeah i don't know ryan right by the way
is this such a bad i'm i'm not going to
be like a leftist and say
he shouldn't be allowed to speak i want
more speakers i think this might be fun
i don't know
you know i used to teach at a university
i still teach university classes and
it's a very common practice to have
certain courses where you bring in guest
speakers
right and there's generally the way we
would do it was
it's a little complicated because it's
academics and everything but you try to
find someone who actually knows
something about the topic and
there really is nothing in hunter
biden's public
record statement behavior or anything
yeah suggests he knows anything about
media polarization yeah and here's the
thing
there's like lots and lots of people out
there doing really really interesting
research on this topic
i can tell you like if you have so many
friends of the same kind of race and
ideological
you know composition you're more likely
to believe this rather than this
and more likely to be conspiratorial and
you could bring all those people in and
actually offer a really great class
yeah if you really wanted to have
someone from the president's family
there you might have someone who's
taught in college you could have dr jill
biden
for instance yeah you know uh kat i
think students might try to kiss his ass
by leaving a shiny eight ball on the
desk
[Laughter]
so yeah just like when i was in college
uh she hasn't been invited to speak yeah
yeah which is insane i know me neither
emerson hello
i have friends emerson is not a real
college okay fine
you got me there i mean look it's like
there are
a lot of people who would be more
knowledgeable right but they're not
famous and i think that's what a lot of
people go for with guest speakers i
agree with you greg i don't ever want to
try to cancel a college or say that i am
you know it has to be shut down because
i am so afraid or all these and you
notice that you don't really see that
you see people kind of
just making fun of how funny it is but
not saying this is unsafe
right this can't happen or i can't go to
school excellent point like nobody
there's nobody like
if if it was a conservative counterpart
to this there would be a whole group of
people saying
i can't be around him i can't go on i
can't be on campus i cannot be on campus
because he might to me i can't be in my
zoom class
yeah tyrus what do you think like when
he was there
what he asked for or like what's he
planning on doing after the speech
okay first of all i think the photo says
it all
looks like a scary dehydrated tim
robbins right there but
the the issue that i'm having with this
is i don't believe anyone else is seeing
this
he's doing it again except this time
it's not an oil field he's sitting on
the board
he's going to dad's got him going to
colleges now
yes he's doing it again his nepotism
you know i mean what is he going to do
during the q a
right what that's going to be like when
a student raises a hand and i have a
question
crack or eight ball which way do you go
you know thanks for asking me
afterwards and we'll figure it out i got
a guy an alley like this is this is bad
he's not an expert on this at all
what he's not an ex didn't they ask him
that in the interview and he
i made great decisions when i was on
crack well here's one of them again well
i mean you got to admit uh for a
crackhead he's gone pretty far
but to be i i think he when he when they
said that there was going to be a q a he
probably heard tna
oh yeah yeah that happens sometimes when
you get up there hearing problems go
julie yeah what's your take on this you
would you would actually enjoy this
i would not i think it's ironic that he
is going to come up to the stage and
talk to a bunch of college students who
are obviously
not going to go very far if this is what
they look up to um
but you know he's going to talk about
fake news after he spent all that time
and
exhausted his efforts in in decrying his
fake laptop
um but i don't understand how they
choose this and what again makes him
qualified because he doesn't have any oh
i'm sorry i know
i know because his dad's the president
oh yes yes
that is true but there are students at
this college in fact that say that
they've been discriminated against
for being republicans right so they're
saying that the college is clearly
tulane it's no surprise here
are playing to the president's pocket so
to speak the school costs
more than 50 000 a year that's
elementary school in new york city
so not really it's kind of a drop in the
bucket it certainly is well
i hope that's humble brag julie i don't
live in new york city anymore